Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Denise RQ
¿Hablas inglés?
(Francés) ¿Hablas francés?
(Chino) ¿Hablas chino?
Si respondiste "yes"
en castellano, francés o chino
y estás viendo esto en español,
es muy probable que formes parte
de la mayoría bilingüe
y políglota del mundo.
Además de viajar con más facilidad
o ver películas sin subtítulos,
saber dos o más idiomas significa
que tu cerebro tiene otro aspecto
y funciona diferente en comparación
con el de tus amigos monolingües.
Entonces, ¿qué significa
realmente saber un idioma?
La habilidad lingüística se mide
según dos habilidades activas,
el hablar y el escribir,
y dos habilidades pasivas,
el escuchar y el leer.
Mientras que un nativo bilingüe
posee casi las mismas habilidades
en ambos idiomas,
la mayoría de los bilingües del mundo
saben y usan sus idiomas
en diferentes proporciones.
Dependiendo de su situación y de la forma
en la cual aprendieron cada idioma
pueden clasificarse en
tres tipos generales.
Por ejemplo, Gabriella,
que se trasladó con su familia desde Perú
a los Estados Unidos a la edad de 2 años.
En su caso de bilingüismo simultáneo
Gabriella desarrolla dos códigos
lingüísticos al mismo tiempo
a través de un único grupo de conceptos,
y aprende inglés y español a la vez
a medida que comprende
el mundo que la rodeaba.
Por su parte, su hermano adolescente
es un bilingüe consecutivo
que trabaja con dos grupos de conceptos
mientras aprende inglés en la escuela
y sigue hablando español
en casa y con los amigos.
Por último, los padres de Gabriella son
probablemente bilingües de edad adulta
que aprendieron un segundo idioma
por medio de su primer idioma.
Debido a que cualquier bilingüe puede
llegar a ser competentes en sus idiomas,
sin importar el acento o la pronunciación,
la diferencia no es evidente para todos.
Pero avances recientes
en la tecnología de exploración cerebral
permite a los neurolingüistas entender
cómo los aspectos específicos
del aprendizaje de idiomas
afectan el cerebro bilingüe.
Se sabe que el hemisferio
izquierdo del cerebro
es dominante y analítico
en los procesos lógicos,
mientras que el hemisferio
derecho es más activo
en los procesos emocionales y sociales,
aunque no se trata
de una clara separación.
El hecho que el idioma
incluye ambas funciones,
mientras que la lateralización
se desarrolla gradualmente con la edad,
ha contribuido a la hipótesis
del período crítico.
Según esta teoría,
los niños aprenden idiomas más fácilmente
porque la plasticidad
de sus cerebros en desarrollo
les permite usar ambos hemisferios
en la adquisición de idiomas,
mientras que en la mayoría de los adultos
el idioma está limitado
en un solo hemisferio,
por lo general, el izquierdo.
Si esto es cierto, aprender un idioma
durante la infancia puede ayudarte
a alcanzar una comprensión holística
de tus contextos social y emocional.
Por el contrario,
estudios recientes demuestran
que el aprendizaje de un segundo
idioma en la edad adulta
muestra menos parcialidad emocional
y un enfoque más racional
a la hora de afrontar problemas
en este segundo idioma
que en el idioma nativo.
Pero independientemente de la edad
de aprendizaje de nuevos idiomas
ser multilingüe le ofrece a tu cerebro
algunas ventajas importantes.
Algunas son incluso visibles,
como una mayor densidad
de la materia gris
que contiene la mayoría
de las neuronas y sinapsis
y más actividad en ciertas áreas
cuando se habla un segundo idioma.
Una intensa actividad de un cerebro
bilingüe durante toda la vida
también puede ayudar a retrasar
la aparición de enfermedades
como el Alzheimer y la demencia
hasta incluso cinco años.
La idea de que el bilingüismo
conlleva muchos beneficios cognitivos
puede parecer obvia hoy en día,
pero hubiera sorprendido
a los primeros expertos.
Antes de la década de los 60,
al bilingüismo se le consideraba
un discapacidad que alentaba
el desarrollo del niño
al forzarlo a usar demasiada energía
para distinguir entre dos idiomas,
una perspectiva basada en gran medida
en estudios sin validez.
Y aunque un estudio más reciente demuestra
que los tiempos de reacción y los errores
aumentan en estudiantes bilingües
durante las pruebas interlingüísticas,
también demuestra que el esfuerzo
y la atención necesaria
para cambiar de un idioma a otro
generan más actividad
y fortalecen potencialmente
la corteza prefrontal dorsolateral.
Esta es la parte del cerebro
que juega un papel importante
en las funciones ejecutivas,
la resolución de problemas,
transición de una tarea a otra
y en la capacidad para filtrar
cualquier información irrelevante.
Así que aunque el bilingüismo
no te haga más inteligente,
sí ayuda a que tu cerebro se mantenga
sano, complejo y activo,
y aunque no hayas tenido la buena fortuna
de aprender un segundo idioma en tu niñez,
nunca es tarde para hacerte un favor
y dar el salto lingüístico
del "Hello" en inglés
al "Hola", "Bon jour" o "NI hao",
porque cuando se trata
de nuestro cerebro,
un poco de ejercicio
puede servirte de mucho.